yeah it's disgusting you're all sick
around here
[Music]
I'm JoJo Rosa
perfect I'm Joe DeRosa
I'm back to answer the internet you big
if you were in a beauty pageant if I was
in a beauty pageant what would my talent
be correct could there be a complaining
category that would be it Penn Oswalt
said to me once uh it's a name drop he
said to me once you could somebody could
give you a bowl of ice cream that sucks
your dick and you figure out a way to
complain about it
would you rather
get videotaped every night you go out
and have to watch it with your
significant others mom
or have their mom get a copy of every
text you send
well I don't have a significant other so
I don't give a [__] [__] hypothetical
you dumb [__] I'd rather bang my
significant others mom on videotape and
then text my significant other about it
if you want 300 million dollars what are
the first three things you would buy I'd
buy a house for my parents I'd buy a
house for myself and I'd buy you a
decent pair of pants
if you can only watch one actor's movie
for the rest of your life who would it
be uh Sam Rockwell
I love Sam Rockwell
who is he
is he you're joking no Sam Rock stop it
but I you don't know who's Sam Rockwell
would probably do if I see him he uh
what the hell is he in
uh he's in the movie Heist one of my
favorite movies by David Mamet he played
Bob Fosse and fossy veerden he was great
in that this is not a catalog worth
being like
this is all I can watch the rest of my
life I love watching Sam Rockwell okay
okay he is great if you could pick one
country to run what would it be it'd be
this place people America I want to make
America great again how much money would
it take for you to give up World Peace
uh it would take enough money that I
could then
spend money to create World Peace but
still have a little left over he would
never so let's say a hundred trillion
dollars maybe that goes world peace that
could do it would you watch a porn with
the hottest girl from your high school
if the dude in it was no it's disgusting
you don't want the money you don't want
this thing
wanna you think I'm gonna want your
porno with my dad in it you don't get to
see like your dream girl from back in
the day you know no that's disgusting
well yeah you're [__] it's disgusting
you're all sick around here what would
your 12 hour crime spree be during The
Purge I would just steal I honestly I
would just steal media I love collecting
media I love collecting records and
video games and DVDs and Blu-rays and
4ks now and video game systems and
electronics I would just steal media
that's I would be laser discs I would be
running out with laserdiscs yes I would
finally start a LaserDisc collection
would you rather be a world-class dancer
a world-class singer or a world-class
fighter world-class singer 100 that's
where you get
if you had to make your sandwiches with
the same two meats and one cheese for
the rest of your life what would you
choose this is a great question white
American cheese okay is my favorite
sandwich cheese I love Italian hoagies
but you can make in my opinion a proper
Italian hoagie would well you I have two
answers for this I would get ham Cappy
which is spicy ham
and Genoa salami and provolone cheese
and then I can make Italian hoagies the
rest of my life right or
I would get white American cheese
regular ham and turkey and maybe yeah
yeah but either a little mayo on that
possibly yeah I mean it's the rest of my
life So eventually an Italian hero
you're doing
oil vinegar maybe balsamic those kind of
things no vinegar when you're doing a
noble balsamic
disgusting what do you put on your
sandwich what kind of Italian hoagie
yeah oil salt pepper oregano vinegar
just don't do the big uh the vinegar but
you do but balsamic of all the vinegars
is the most egregious to me to ever put
on a sandwich
oh fresh mutts shut up what kind of
[__] sandwich shop do you run I run a
good one you've been eating in these
[__] delis too much dude I don't I
personally don't care for mozzarella
I hate when people say much I know I
hate it so I hate when people say
Sammy's stop it no I don't like fresh
mozzarella on a sandwich look I'm not
saying it can't work on a sandwich I eat
it every day as your only cheese on a
sandwich you're gonna get sick of it in
about four days
to every day just straight up listen we
all love uh a Caprese salad okay as far
as a cheese elevating a sandwich so
you're putting like mozzarella is not
the cheese I don't put mozzarella on
sandwiches unless it's like a parm and
it's melted but even then it has to have
parmesan cheese sprinkled in or it
doesn't have flavor to me the best
mozzarella if they're gonna melt it down
on in my opinion if you're going to melt
it down on something isn't like a really
good fresh mozzarella like really good
New York Pizza that yellowy [__] that's
that that's got flavor in it uh fresh
mozzarella is great for salad and stuff
like that but I do not prefer it on a
sandwich any day of the week I want a
provolone sharp provolone an Asiago uh
something with a little kick to it a
little flavor if you could do the patron
saint of something what would it be I'd
like to be the patron saint
that goes up to people praying for
things and goes
it's not going to happen like trust me
like I know God it's not gonna happen
but you know it for a fact do it for a
fact you're like the deliverer bad news
well would you also be the guy who's
like hey no and you're gonna get it no
no no only the bad news it's not gonna
happen so God God will be like that guy
we're gonna cure his cancer but over
there tell that guy his team's not
winning it's not gonna happen just to
put in perspective when I save seats in
a movie theater for somebody when you
used to have to do that I enjoyed saying
to people is
like people sliding down the aisle like
coming through sorry it's taken oh that
feels
that gives me Glee that is probably one
of people's like least favorite
situations to be in and you relish it
get one more than anything give it to me
all right thank you for watching answer
the internet please subscribe to the
channel comment below on other
celebrities you'd like to see and make
sure you hit the Bell to get
notifications when new episodes come out